the BBC is not acting impartially by
caving in to Tory MPS who are
complaining about Gary lineker they've
got this one badly wrong and now they're
very very exposed as is the government
because at the heart of this is the
government's failure on the Asylum
system and rather than take
responsibility for the mess they've made
the government is casting around to
blame anybody else Gary lineker the BBC
civil servants The Blob what they should
be doing is standing up accepting
they've broken the Asylum system and
tell using telling us what they're going
to do to actually fix it not whinging on
about Gary lineker
well the leader of the lib Dems red
Davey has just tweeted saying the match
of the day Saga has shown failure at the
top of the BBC and the needs to urgently
protect its independence we need
leadership that can uphold British
values and withstand conservative
attacks under Richard Sharp's leadership
this that's of course the chairman of
the BBC this hasn't been the case he
must resign